The first thing we need to do is to define a quantum state vector Chi
theta for each angle theta, as you can see here on the screen.
So, Chi theta is equal to
cosine theta times cat zero plus sine theta times cat
one, and here by the way,
we're thinking about
angles in terms of radians.
So for example, here's the vector we get when theta is equal to pi over
four, which is 45 degrees.
Cosine of pi over four
and sine of pi over four are both equal to one over
the square root of two, so this is just another
name for the plus state.
Here's another example when theta is equal to three times pi over eight, and in case you don't
happen to know the sine
and cosine of three times pi over eight off the top of your head,
here's a table of the sines and the cosines that we're
actually going to need
throughout this example
and includes the ones that we need for this particular vector.
Now, if we wanna take the inner product between any two of these vectors
for angles, alpha and beta let's say, it's
straightforward to do that.
We only have real number
entries in these vectors so there are no complex
conjugates to worry about and we obtain the product of the cosines
plus the product of the the sines, and we can use one of the
so-called angle addition formulas
to simplify that, it's the
cosign of the difference between the angles and
because the cosine function
is symmetric around zero,
it doesn't actually matter which order we take them in.
If you don't have these sorts
of trigonometric identities committed to memory, by
the way, you're not alone, but you don't have to remember them,
you can just look them up. This one does make sense
though when you think about the geometric interpretation
of the inner product
between real unit vectors as the cosine of the angle between them.
If we compute the inner
product of the tensor product of any two of these vectors
with the Phi plus state, we get a similar looking expression
except that there's a squared
of two in the denominator.
This is the first time
that the Phi plus state has appeared in the context
of this example by the way, and we'll see exactly why we're interested
in this particular inner product shortly, but for the moment let's
just observe that we obtain the same expression that we had
for the inner product divided
by the square root of two and so we can simplify as before.
Next, we'll define a
unitary matrix, U theta, for each angle theta
like you see right here,
it's not difficult to
check that this is indeed a unitary matrix.
The key thing we need to
recognize is that the vectors si theta is orthogonal to
the vector si theta plus pi over two, and that makes sense
because if we rotate by pi over two, which is 90 degrees, we
get an orthogonal vector.
If we then multiply U
theta to U theta dagger, we get the identity matrix.
Intuitively speaking,
what this matrix does as an operation is to
map si theta to cat zero and si theta plus pi two to cat one.
At this point, we have
everything that we need to describe Alice and Bob's strategy.
First, just like we had for teleportation and superdense coding, Alice and Bob will start out by sharing an e-bit.
Alice holds a qubit A,
bob holds a qubit B, and together the two Qubits
are in the Phi plus state.
Alice's actions are as follows; she looks at the bit X that
she receives from the referee,
and if X is equal to zero,
she performs U zero on A, which happens to be the
same thing as doing nothing because U zero is the identity matrix,
effects is equal to one on the other hand, she applies U pi over four to A.
After she applies one
of the two operations, she measures A using a
standard basis measurement and sends whatever result
she gets to the referee.
Bob does something very similar, his qubit is called B of course, and he receives Y from the
referee as opposed to X
but the key difference is
that he uses different angles for his unitary operations.
If Y is equal to zero, he
applies U pi over eight, and if Y is equaled one, he applies u negative pi over eight.
And we'll see why these choices of angles are good choices shortly,
it's not at all obvious.
And here is a circuit diagram
that expresses this strategy.
Bob is in the top and Alice
is on the bottom this time, here is the e-bit that is coming in
and these are the unitary
gates that Alice and Bob might or might not apply
depending upon what X and Y are.
For this one and this one, we have gates that are being controlled either by the bit X or by the bit Y
and for these two right here, we have what kind of
look like control gates except that the circle isn't filled in.
And what this means is
that if the control bit is set to zero, then the gate is performed and if the control is set to
one, then nothing happens.
So, it's just like an
ordinary control gate except that the roles of zero and one for the control are swapped.
So, effectively, Bob
performs this gate right here if Y is equal to zero, he
performs this gate right here